rolling the clock forward you and elon
tweeted recently about population
collapse what do you think is going to
happen there
oh well i've thought for at least 10
years that the biggest problem in 50
years will be that there's just not
enough people i remember hearing you say
a few years ago that you thought we'd
peak at about nine billion yeah we
probably won't hit nine yeah and i think
about stats because think about how
crazy it is to think
that we might be living on earth right
now
at a time with the most number of humans
that are ever going to exist at one time
ever yeah that's highly probable and you
know in the past
the population collapse
in developed countries is precipitous
right it's like it fall we fall off a
cliff because it's the same everyone
knows this from the pandemic the r
naught number
if fewer people are reproducing next
generation you have fewer people to
reproduce as fewer people are
reproducing and it
yeah yeah yeah
well i i worked on
un committee
it's got to be ten years ago now
um to help draft the un secretary's
general's report on sustainable economic
development and so i looked at all sorts
of things like that i was very curious
for example about
because people have been beating the
overpopulation drum since
well it really kicked in in the 1960s
you know because there were dire
predictions by the year 2000 the club of
rome came out and said well there'll be
riots and mass starvation and mass
movement of of migrants and all the
things you hear about climate change
because there's too many people on the
planet and that just didn't happen at
all that was just that it wasn't just
wrong it was anti-true it was absolutely
wrong what happened instead was that
everyone got way richer and the bottom
section of the population in terms of
economic distribution got lifted out of
poverty inequality still exists but
that's that power law phenomena we
already talked about not that that's
trivial it's just unbelievably difficult
to determine what to do with there are
solutions but certainly getting rid of
capitalism isn't the solution
and so
i looked at population trends and first
of all found
not that this is an act of genius or
anything that as soon as you educate
women
and
the the size of family shrinks
precipitously like below replacement and
that's partly because women have other
options that that's a huge thing this
play out oh yes i mean all the all the
countries in the west are way below
replacement korea is way below
replacement south korea japan way below
replacement
yeah yeah i think the number one not
good number one on the planet it might
be chad
chad the country in terms of growth uh
eight children on average yeah i think
nigeria will have more people in it than
china by the end of the century
so
yeah yeah yeah and musk you know he's a
far
looking
man and
and so he's looking
around the apocalyptic corner let's say
oh we're running out of people and what
that means of course is that you run out
of young people right you don't run out
of old people first because everyone who
is here now is going to be 30 years
older in 30 years and
it'll be young people we don't have
enough of and of course young people are
the ones who do the innovation and are
going to do most of the heavy lifting
etc and so there's going to be a
terrible shortage of young people well
you see this with some of the things
that i i posted that o s data 50.1
percent of women childless by 30 and
both men and women are replying to that
tweet saying well good there's too many
people on the planet in any case i'm
thinking how
this
npc midwitery
is so dangerous because it makes people
believe that they actually have
something grounded backing up their
claims yeah yeah well and that this idea
that the planet has too many people on
it this is
there's no
sentiment more implicitly genocidal than
that statement
[Laughter]
so what do you mean too many people
exactly and what do you mean the planet
and what do you propose to do about that
exactly mass abortion is that your
answer or should we do something a
little more dramatic maybe we'll just
shame people out of having children and
i've seen people do that literally i saw
a professor when i was at an um
a ted i think it was it
doesn't matter it was a number of
professors talking to a couple hundred
students and one of the professors who
was an environmentalist activist type
and he got up on stage and shook his
finger to the whole young crowd saying
that him and his wife had only decided
to have one child which was in my
opinion one child too many for him and
told all the young people there if they
had a shred of ethical decency that they
would lim severely limit their
reproductive potential and
i stood up and said that i thought that
was the most one of the most appalling
things i'd ever heard anyone in academia
say to young people which is really
saying something because they say plenty
of appalling things and it was a very
uncomfortable moment and he huffed off
the stage but
you know in a frenzy talking about how
you couldn't talk about such things
without being pilloried on ethical
grounds and yeah that's for sure you
come out
as a what emissary of the academic
establishment you tell young people that
humanity is so corrupt that they should
seriously consider not propagating
because that violates the deepest of
ethical norms and you think that's a
good thing and that that's your right
and
it was just
beyond comprehension it's beyond
comprehension but it's associated with
like a deeply rooted
existential self-hatred
and and i mean hatred at the level of
humanity is like a virus on the planet
that we're a cancerous group alex
epstein calls this human racism
right
right right it's that yeah well we're a
cancer on the planet you know unchecked
growth just like a cancer
it's like that's us say a cancer it's
okay we know where your heart is
located
because what's what's the implications
for for a doctrine like that what do you
do with a cancer cut it out yeah that's
for sure poison it or whatever whatever
there's nothing you don't do to a cancer
so you're gonna use a metaphor like that
there's too many people on the planet
you can use a metaphor like that
you know and then you're gonna you're
gonna also decide that you're virtuous
while you're using it because you're on
the side of the planet whatever the hell
that means
so yeah it's it's unbelievable and a
huge part of it's rooted in this
existential
shame and
and horror at the condition of being
human and the fact that life is rife
with suffering and a lot of it's
unjustified and
you know it's a mephistophelian
position so mephistopheles was laid out
portrayed in girth is faust
that's
the story of a man who sold his soul to
the devil for knowledge it's a story of
intellectual pride and
gurtha stands in relationship to german
literature in the same manner that
shakespeare stands in relationship to
english literature
girth is mephistopheles
says straight out twice in in the play
once in the first
his two books and once in the first book
and once in a second girth that hasn't
restated twice
existence is such a foul thing
because of all its suffering essentially
that it would be better if it was merely
enough annihilated
and that's the mephistophelian stance
this whole show should just come to a
halt look at how corrupt people are evil
reigns everywhere it's nothing but will
to power we're destroying the planet
with our unchecked ambition all of it
rooted in greed and and and
machiavellianism and jockeying for
position and we're so contemptible that
we should just roll up and die
and we should shame women into not
having children and we should shame men
so they never manifest any planet
destroying ambition and
it's it's unbelievably appalling it goes
all the way down to the bottom
the bottom of things that's what's
tearing our culture apart this dispute
about
the nature of existence at the most
fundamental level
so and the universities have come out on
the wrong side what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace